MARIA: AND FIRST THIS MORNING,
BREAKING NEWS RIGHT NOW.
WITH NEW NUMBERS FROM THE SURGE
OF MIGRANTS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER FOR THE MONTH OF JUNE,
THIS FOX NEWS DRONE VIDEO SHOWS
BETWEEN 400 AND 500 MIGRANTS,
PREDOMINANTLY FROM VENEZUELA AND
CUBA, CROSSING INTO EAGLE PASS,
TEXAS, ON WEDNESDAY.
OF COURSE, IT HAS BECOME A
FAMILIAR SIGHT, STREAMS OF
MIGRANTS IN GROUPS OF 10, 20,
30, HUNDREDS FROM MEXICO,
HONDURAS, GUATEMALA PILING INTO
AMERICA’S WIDE OPEN BORDER EVERY
DAY AND NIGHT, FORCING THE STATE
OF TEXAS TO STEP UP ITS EFFORTS
TO DEFEND THE STATE AND COUNTRY,
INCLUDING GOVERNOR ABBOTT’S
EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH AUTHORIZES
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND NATIONAL GUARD TO
RETURN AP REHEMMEDDED MIGRANTS
BACK TO THE BORDER ON TOP OF HIS
LAUNCHING OF THE $3 BILLION
BORDER SECURITY MISSION KNOWN AS
OPERATION LONE STAR.
THE IMPACT OF THIS WIDE OPEN
BORDER FROM HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO
DEATHS AND ILLICIT DRUG
TRAFFICKING HAS SPARKED A NUMBER
OF TEXAS COUNTIES TO DECLARE
THIS WILL LITERALLY AN INVASION
OF AMERICA.
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT JOINS ME
RIGHT NOW.
GOVERNOR, IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU
THIS MORNING, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
THANK YOU, MARIA.
MARIA: IS THIS AN INVASION?
>> LISTEN, THESE COUNTIES ARE
ARE DEALING WITH SOMETHING
THAT’S COMPLETELY UNPRECEDENTED.
REMEMBER THIS, IT WAS JUST TWO
YEARS AGO WE HAD THE LOWEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND APPREHENSIONS
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OVER AND
ELIMINATED ALL OF THE POLICIES
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IN
PLACE, AND IT HAS LED TO THIS
UNPRECEDENTED, OVERWHELMING
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
YOU GAVE SOME OF THE NUMBERS.
HERE’S SOMETHING MORE IMPORTANT.
THERE’S A RECORD NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
FROM MORE THAN 150 # DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
GLOBE.
WE’RE SEEING OVER THE FOURTH OF
JULY, FOR EXAMPLE, IN JUST THE
DEL RIO SECTOR WHICH IS ONLY ONE
OF FIVE SECTORS IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS, THERE WERE ABOUT 5,000
PEOPLE EITHER AP APPREHENDED OR
WHO WERE GOTAWAYS.
BUT IT GETS WORSE, MARIA,
BECAUSE LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS WE’RE DEALING WITH.
YOU REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE TRACTOR-TRAILER TRUCKING
WHERE 53 PEOPLE LOST THEIR
LIVES.
THINGS LIKE THAT HAPPEN ALL OF
THE TIME, SO MUCH SO THAT THE9
UNITED NATIONS DECLARED THE
BORDER BETWEEN TEXAS OR THE
UNITED STATES AND MEXICO TO BE
THE WORST DEATH BORDER AND MOST
DANGEROUS BORDER IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
BUT ON TOP OF THINGS HIKE THAT,
WE KNOW ABOUT 42 TERRORISTS WHO
HAVE BEEN APPREHENDED COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, THAT’S NOT
COUNTING THE GOTAWAYS, AND THEN
THERE’S THE FENTANYL COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
SO, YES, WE DO HAVE AN INVASION
DRIVEN BY THE CARTELS COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDER THAT ARE
POURING PEOPLE INTO OUR COUNTRY
AT UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS.
MARIA: IT’S ABSOLUTELY
EXTRAORDINARY, SIR.
AND I KNOW THAT THE WORD
INVASION COMES WITH TECHNICAL
RESPONSES FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
SO ARE YOU RELUCTANT TO SAY IT’S
AN INVASION?
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS AN
INVASION?
IF.
>> SO THE TECHNICAL REASONS FOR
IT LIE IN THE CONSTITUTION.
THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION, ARTICLE IV,
SECTION FOUR, ARTICLE HER
SECTION 10.
IN THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT I
ISSUED THIS PAST WEEK, I
REFERENCED BOTH OF THOSE, PLUS I
REFERENCE A PROVISION OF THE
TEXAS CONSTITUTION THAT ALSO
USES THE WORD INVASION.
THE PURPOSE OF USING THOSE WORDS
IS IT TRIGGERS CERTAIN
ADDITIONAL WAYS AND STRATEGIES
THAT AT STATES CAN USE THEIR
POWERS TO TRY TO PROTECT AGAINST
ACTIONS SUCH AS THIS THAT ARE
DRIVEN BY THE CARTELS.
MARIA: OKAY, I UNDERSTAND.
WE HAVE PUT UP ON THE SCREEN
WAYS THAT YOU AND YOUR TEAM IN
TEXAS ARE DEFENDING THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, SIR, EVERYTHING FROM,
OBVIOUSLY, YOUR LONE STAR PLAN,
OPERATION LONE STAR, TO
ALLOCATING RESOURCES DEPLOYING
THOUSANDS OF MARTIAL GUARD
SOLDIERS -- NATIONAL GUARD
SOLDIERS, SIGNING NEW LAWS,
CRACKING DOWN ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND, AS YOU SAY, THE
FENTANYL AS WELL.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT THE SUPREME
COURT’S RULING THAT CAN END THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO BORDER TO
IMPACT TRAFFIC, AND WHAT ABOUT
TITLE 42, DO YOU THINK THAT’S
NEXT AFTER A FEDERAL JUDGE
PRETTY MUCH PUT A TEMPORARY
PAUSE ON IT BACK IN MAY?
>> SO IT IS GOING TO BE A TOTAL
DISASTER.
FIRST, IT WAS TEXAS LEADING THE
WAY IN GETTING COURT DECISIONS
TO KEEP THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY AND KEEP THE TITLE 42
POLICY IN PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU POINT OUT, THE
SUPREME COURT HAS STRICKEN DOWN
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
LET ME JUST GIVE YOU THE NUMBERS
THAT WERE PROVIDED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY PREDICTED THAT AFTER THE HE
ELIMINATION OF THESE POLICIES,
WE SHOULD HAVE ABOUT 18,000
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY PER DAY.
EXTRAPOLATE THAT FOR AN ANNUAL
BASIS, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
THAN 6 MILLION PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER A YEAR.
TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT, THE
LARGEST CITY IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS IS HOUSTON.
WE WILL HAVE ABOUT ONE HOUSTON
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER IN,
EVERY YEAR.
IT TOOK MORE THAN 100 YEARS TO
CREATE HOUSTON, NOW WE WILL BE
ADDING A HOUSTON EVERY YEAR.
MARIA: WOW.
>> THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS, AND THE
REASON AMERICANS ARE SO ANGRY
ABOUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
APPROACH TO THE BORDER.
MARIA: YEAH, AND WE SEE THE
IMPLICATIONS EVERY DAY.
THERE WAS A REPORT ON FOX NEWS
LAST WEEK ABOUT SPECIFIC CRIMES
COMMITTED BY ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
AND SO-CALLED GOTAWAYS.
I’M TOLD THAT THERE IS AT LEAST
500,000 GOTAWAYS, AND EVEN THE
GOTAWAYS THAT WE KNOW OF, THAT
WERE SEEN ON SURVEILLANCE CAMERA
GETTING INTO THE COUNTRY.
IS THERE ANYTHING MORE YOU CAN
DO ABOUT THIS, GOVERNOR?
WE PUT A LIST OF ALL OF THE
EFFORTS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
MAKING, BUT THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE WHO SAY WE NEED THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS TO DO MORE.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU DO ABOUT IT?
>> SO LET’S GO -- AND I HAVEN’T
BEEN ABLE TO SEE WHAT YOU PUT UP
ON THE SCREEN, SO LET’S GO
THROUGH THE THINGS THAT WE’RE
DOING.
SO IF WE HAVE A CATEGORY CALLED
TURNBACKS AND WE TURN BACK TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS WHO TRY
TO GET ACROSS THE BORDER, AND WE
DENY THEM EVEN COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
ONCE THEY CROSS THE BORDER, WE
NOW HAVE TWO OPTIONS.
ONE IS TO ARREST THEM, AND WE’VE
MADE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ARRESTS FOR PEOPLE, PUT THEM IN
JAIL, AND NOW WE HAVE THIS NEW
TOOL WHERE WE ARE NOW RETURNING
THEM TO THE BORDER.
ALL OF THESE ARE COMPLETELY
UNPRECEDENTED.
NO STATE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA HAS
EVER DONE THAT.
AND, MARIA, THAT’S ON TOP OF
DOING THINGS LIKE TEXAS BEING
THE ONLY STATE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY TO BUILD OUR OWN BORDER
WALL, TEXAS BEING THE ONLY STATE
IN HISTORY WHERE WE HAVE LAID
DOWN MILE AFTER MILE AFTER MILE
OF RAZOR WIRE AS BARRIERS TO
PREVENT PEOPLE COMING IN.
TEXAS IS USING EVERY TOOL AND
STRATEGY THAT WE CAN.
IT IS TIME NOW FOR CONGRESS TO
STEP UP UNDER ARTICLE I, SECTION
EIGHT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION.
CONGRESS HAS THE DIRECT
AUTHORITY TO CALL FOR AN
INVASION AND TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT SECURING OUR BORDER.
IT’S TIME NOW FOR CONGRESS TO
STOP TALKING ABOUT IT AND STEP
UP AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
MARIA: ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO TEXAS’ BORDER
SECURITY MISSION, BUT FIRST,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO, LOPEZ
OBRADOR, ENDORSING YOUR DEMOCRAT
OPPONENT, BETO O’ROURKE, MT.
GOVERNOR’S RACE THIS NOVEMBER?
-- IN THE GOVERNOR’S RACE?
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS JOE BIDEN’S
PICK.
NOW YOU’VE GOT THE PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO ENDORSING BETO O’ROURKE.
>> THERE’S A REASON FOR IT, AND
THAT IS ALL OF THESE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COMING FROM MEXICO
INTO TEXAS, THEY ARE ALLOWED
INTO MEXICO BY PRESIDENT LOPEZ
OBRADOR.
AND THEY’RE COMING FROM
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
FOR ONE, PRESIDENT LOPEZ
OBRADOR, HE CAN KEEP THEM OUT OF
MEXICO IF HE WANTED TO, BUT HE
DOES NOT WANT TO.
HE WANTS TO FUNNEL THEM INTO THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
MARIA, CAN YOU IMAGINE ANYTHING
WORSE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA THAN HAVING LOPEZ
OBRADOR WORKING WITH BIDEN AND
O’ROURKE WITH THE OPEN DOOREDDER
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, IT WOULD BE
A CRUSHING DISASTER FROM WHICH
WE MAY NEVER RECOVER FROM BETO
O’ROURKE WERE WORKING HAND IN
HAND WITH JOE BIDEN AND THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO.
IT WOULD DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
MARIA: MEANWHILE, INSTEAD OF
GOING TO THE BORDER AND DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES, PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S DOJ IS INVESTIGATING
YOUR STATE AND OPERATION LONE
STAR.
THEY’RE TALKING ABOUT POTENTIAL
CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS IN THAT
THEY RECEIVED INDICATIONS THAT
TEXAS DPS IS TARGETING CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS FOR ARREST ARE ON
THE BASIS OF RACE AND NATIONAL
ORIGIN.
GOVERNOR, WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> MARIA, YOU KNOW I’M A FORMER,
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE AS WELL AS
A FORMER TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WE MAKE
SURE IS CONSISTENT WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
POLITICAL ATTACK BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT WANT US
TO TRY TO STOP HIS OPEN BORDER
POLICIES.
AND SO WE ARE FRUSTRATED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S OPEN
BORDER POLICY AND THAT THEY’RE
USING ANY TOOL AND STRATEGY THEY
CAN TO TRY TO TAMP DOWN TEXAS’
EFFORTS TO ENFORCE THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS AND TO SECURE
OUR BORDER.
MARIA: YEAH.
AND YET HE WON’T VISIT THE
BORDER, BUT HE WILL VISIT SAUDI
can occur.
ARABIA IN THE UPCOMING WEEK.
HE’S TRYING TO GET THE SAUDIS TO
PUT MORE OIL ON THE MARKET EVEN
THOUGH TEXAS IS OIL AND GAS
RICH.
TELL US ABOUT TEXAS’ POTENTIAL
TO PRODUCE ENOUGH OIL TO REDUCE
PAIN AT THE PUMP AND ELIMINATE
THE NEED TO GO HAT IN HAND TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
>> I MEAN, IT’S SO EMBARRASSING,
IT’S SO TWO-FACED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GOING OFF TO
SAUDI ARABIA, BEGGING THEM TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL WHEN WE HAVE
THE OIL RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
TEXAS IS ONE OF IF NOT THE MOST
PROLIFIC PRODUCER OF OIL IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
AND ALL WE NEED IS THE PERMITS
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THE AUTHORIZATION TO BUILD MORE
REFINERIES.
WE COULD BE PRODUCING THE
GASOLINE THAT WOULD LOWER PRICES
AT THE PUMP IF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD UNLEASH THE
AMERICAN OIL AND GAS INGENUITY.
WE COULD PRODUCE ALL THE OIL
THAT WE NEED --
MARIA: YEAH.
>> GET THIS, AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OIL
FROM THE FEDERAL STRATEGIC OIL
RESERVES AND SHIPPED IT TO OTHER
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE GLOBE AS
OPPOSED TO KEEPING IT IN THE
UNITED STATES AND REFINING IT
HERE, TURNING IT INTO GASOLINE.
MARIA: YEAH.
>> BIDEN IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE HAVE SUCH HIGH GASOLINE
PRICES.
MARIA: WELL, THAT’S RIGHT.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SOME OF THAT
OIL ACTUALLY WENT TO CHINA, OUR
LARGE ADVERSARY.
REAL QUICK BEFORE YOU GO, ALL OF
THIS IS NOT FALLING ON DEAF
EARS.
WE JUST SAW REPRESENTATIVE MAYRA
FLORES FLIP A SEAT IN A THEM THE
ACCURATE TICKET IN TEXAS --
DEMOCRAT.
DO YOU BELIEVE WE’LL SEE MORE OF
THIS GOING INTO THE NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS, AND WILL WE SEE THE
BORDER STATE VOTERS REACT?
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> RIGHT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A MASSIVE OF
RED WAVE ALONG THE BORDER.
THE BORDER COUNTIES AND THE
BORDER DISTRICTS HAVE
HISTORICALLY ALWAYS BEEN
DEMOCRAT.
THE ONE THAT MAYRA FLORES WON
WAS ALWAYS HELD BY A DEMOCRAT,
IT’S NOW HELD BY A REPUBLICAN.
WE WILL SEE OTHER REPUBLICAN
VICTORIES ALONG THE BORDER.
I WILL DO EXTRAORDINARILY WELL
ON THE BORDER AND IT’S BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE BORDER ARE
SO ANGRY ABOUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S APPROACH TO THE
OPEN BORDER POLICY, AND THEY’RE
GOING TO BE VOTING AGAINST THE
BIDEN AD MANAGER, VOTING FOR --
ADMINISTRATION, VOTING FOR
REPUBLICANS WHO THEY KNOW ARE
GOING TO STEP UP, SECURING OUR
BORDER.
MARIA: GOVERNOR, GOOD TO HAVE
YOU THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR